today i'm going to be sharing five
things i wish i knew before i started
playing elden ring so let's start with
what is the most important of these by
far and that is that every enemy has a
hidden posture bar which if you deplete
this posture bar you'll open them up to
a critical strike to deal massive damage
if you've played sakurail you'll know
all about breaking an enemy's posture
but the basic idea is that you're
rewarded for maintaining consistent
damage on an enemy light attacks will
prevent the enemy's posture from
restoring fully but you'll need to
employ jumping attacks charged r2
attacks or strong charge spells if you
want to consistently break the posture
of your enemies of course there are
other ways to break their posture as
well such as the new countering system
with shields and also the parrying
system here's the thing a lot of this is
even possible on bosses and yes all the
bosses have this hidden posture bar as
well a couple of minor boss spoilers
coming up so if you want to go in
completely blind go ahead and skip to
this point in the video alright so in
the clip here you can see me staggering
the glenstone dragon using the rock
sling spell which is made more powerful
by the meteorite staff i'm using we'll
touch more on why the meteorite staff
makes it more powerful later in the
video it took three of these spells in
roughly a 15 to 20 second window or so
to consistently break his posture now
because this posture bar is hidden to
the player the only way you'll know how
much damage you need is by experimenting
with different attacks on various
enemies here against bowles the carrion
knight after fighting him a few times i
realized that one charged r2 attack and
two r2 jumping attacks were enough to
stagger him if you do happen to have
these moments and fights where you
aren't able to keep hitting these heavy
attacks don't panic you can keep the
enemies posture bar from fully
recovering by hitting them with light
attacks this is where those smaller
quick items like throwing knives can
really come in handy and of course if
you're close enough you can always throw
in an r1 attack as well moving on to
number two i've actually noticed a lot
of newcomers to from software games or
checking out eldon ring which is awesome
to be honest with you even as a souls
veteran there have been a number of
mechanics i only discovered after
numerous hours of playing the game which
takes us to number two on our list and
that's that you do have the ability to
switch to your offhand weapon while on
horseback this one drove me crazy for a
while guys it seems like such a simple
one that i knew there had to be a way to
do this in the game maybe it even tells
you in the game and i just completely
missed it but if like me you've yet to
figure it out here's how it goes by
default your right hand weapon will be
equipped when you're riding horseback
pressing l1 however doesn't use your
left hand weapon instead it uses your
right hand weapon but swings on the left
side now i'm playing as a mage right now
and i usually like running with my staff
and my left hand and my sword in my
right hand of course you can see the
problem here whenever i hop on my horse
i couldn't figure out a way to switch to
the staff in my left hand but this one's
actually super simple all you have to do
is press the button combination for two
handing your weapon while you're on
horseback so for ps4 ps5 this is going
to be triangle and r1 at the same time
again if you're on horseback rather than
two-handing your right-hand weapon it
will instead switch to your left-hand
weapon now if you're a mage like me and
running the staff in your left hand
what's kind of strange about this setup
is that you will have to use r1 to cast
the spells when you're on horseback
which of course if you were on foot and
holding it in your left hand you'd be
using l1 to cast while you were walking
around normally so that's kind of a
little quirk of the system but it does
still work and it does keep you from
having to put the staff in your right
hand instead alright for our next tip
we're going to stick with torrent here
because did you know there's actually
two ways that you can dismount him of
course the basic way you can set to a
hotkey so you can press triangle on
either one of the directional buttons on
the d-pad or you can even set them to
the quick access menu on the bottom
where you can just press square now the
thing about this system is that it's
kind of slow to dismount especially when
you're in the heat of battle and i just
kept thinking there has to be a way to
leap off torrent while i'm in the middle
of a battle especially if you're wanting
to go from being on horseback to
fighting on foot instead you may think
you just pressed the jump button twice
but no you see torrent has a double jump
ability so if you press your jump button
twice he's just going to simply double
jump but if you're wanting to leap off
him quickly it's actually going to be
the crouch button so l3 for console
players now this can really help out
when you're in the heat of battle and
you need to dismount quickly to try and
engage some enemies on foot rather than
on horseback and even in some boss
fights as well our next tip relates to
the open world as with most from
software games they ask a lot of the
player and put the responsibility on you
to discover things about the game either
through trial and error or carefully
reading item descriptions players can
also help each other through the
messaging system found throughout the
game and honestly early in the game and
even the first several hours of
exploring lim grave you're presented
with a lot of information in a
relatively short amount of time elden
ring is a vast game and when you first
start your map will mostly be blocked
out you probably already know you can
open up more of the map by finding
various map fragments which are
scattered throughout the world they're
always found at one of these little
totems now what you may not know is that
these totems can actually appear on your
map before you've unlocked that area
whenever you find yourself exploring
uncharted territory on your map be sure
to check frequently and see if you have
a little brown icon like this that shows
up and then as soon as you see that icon
pop up on your map you want to go to it
because this icon will show you the
exact position of the totem which of
course has the map fragment with it i
believe when they appear on your map is
tied to either proximity so maybe if you
get close to it or how much you've
explored in an area but i'm not 100 sure
on that one so if any of you out there
know exactly how that happens and when
it shows up leave a comment below to let
me know the fifth thing i wish i knew
before i started elden ring is that some
items have incredibly powerful passive
abilities and you'll only know if you
read each item description carefully now
we already talked about how from
software and eldon ring in particular
expect a lot of their players and this
is an example of that the meteorite
staff i mentioned earlier in the video
actually has a passive ability that
boosts gravity-based sorcery which you
can see here by the way you'll know it's
gravity-based sorcery based on the
purple coloring of both the spell and
its icon also this raptor's black
feathers armor actually includes a
passive ability for a 10 boost in your
jump attacks these are just a couple of
these items there are a bunch of these
items like this throughout the game so
make sure you're always checking those
item descriptions because at first
glance you may think oh this piece of
armor doesn't really look that great but
then you notice it has some incredible
passive ability that might make it
actually worth it for your build if you
guys are curious about my first
playthrough of elden ring i'm posting it
all on my dedicated let's play channel
which you can check out on the right
side of your screen now as always thank
you all so much for watching i'll talk
to you again soon